hey guys now this is another video
request and some of you asked me Daniel
can you give me some advice or tips on
how to talk to the camera confidently so
that's what I'm gonna do in this video
now if you haven't been watching my
channel from the beginning you need to
know that this channel is only around
two and a half years old my first videos
oh man they were terrible but over the
years I learned how to talk comfortably
and confidently and I'm gonna give you
my best tips that's definitely gonna
help you let's get to it
[Music]
mistakes mistakes make you strong
alright guys now you know me by now so
I'm not gonna waste any of your time so
let's start with the first
[Music]
know what you want to say don't just
jump right into a video do your research
first if you want to talk about a
certain topic like doing a certain book
review you got to read the book first
right and you make some notes about it
if you don't know what you're talking
about people can see it so they're gonna
see you lack the confidence and it's
gonna be a terrible video confidence
comes from doing the research and then
knowing what you're talking about a
movie write it down you gotta write down
what you want to say because this will
prevent you from talking too much or too
little so you just hit that sweet spot
your video should be very concise the
biggest mistake most people do when they
talk on videos is they talk too much and
then they'll lose the interest of the
viewers so your speech should be short
and sweet condensed and sweet and then
you won't waste people's time now of
course there's a couple of ways you can
do this it depends on what works for you
but you can write down just a few bullet
points poor you can write out the whole
script now most of the time I like to
write my whole script down just to get
it out of my head right because my first
language Afrikaans not English so I
write it all out just to see how it all
comes together
I personally write it out in paragraphs
and then cut all the excess fat or the
parts that are not necessary and only
when I'm fully happy with it only then I
start to film and I put my script right
under the camera just to remind myself
of what I want to say and then of course
you can also get a teleprompter which is
what they use to give the news on TV but
be careful here because you don't want
to come off as a robot and lose your
charisma people connect with people and
if you're down to earth if you look
natural and normal and people will
connect with you
[Music]
relaxed body language now I'm not
talking about slouching body language
I'm just talking about being relaxed
people can see when you look
uncomfortable or when you're tense you
see what I mean
so before you feel make sure you're
comfortable get a comfortable chair it
won't close get some coffee make it
comfortable for yourself and if you do
that and it's easier to focus just on
your message the more you think about
things like what should I do with my my
hands what should I do with my arms you
see some people they struggle with it
because the more they think about these
things then they start to focus less on
what they want to say and then they
start to stumble with their words they
start to say words like it's like these
are your crutch words or your Fuller
words when you're not sure what to say
next or when you're busy thinking of
something then you use crutch words now
the problem with these words are that
you will come across as being less
confident and it will bring down the
quality of your video well with that
said you can also fix a lot of your
mistakes with video editing but I'm
gonna explain a little bit more than
that later on now when you speak to the
camera use your body language the same
way that you would use it when you speak
to somebody in a normal conversation
just let it flow naturally now here's a
few tips if you keep thinking about your
hands and your arms you're not sure what
to do then just let them hang naturally
there's a table just put them on the
table there's no table then let them
just hang and then you continue the
video and then just as eye contact is
important in a real life it's also
important in videos so you've got our
look at a camera most of the time but
then it's also fine if you sometimes
look a little bit off camera when you're
thinking of something right because
that's mom and then you can also use
your hands just to explain things to put
more emphasis on what you're saying you
see what I just did there emphasis and
what I'm saying it comes naturally when
you think Jim doing it again think when
you just focus on the message and what
you want to say see these hands they
don't stop but don't do it too much when
I started the channel man I just went
like this and I explained things in my
hand just it just went when I everywhere
but it's too distracting to a lot of
people so don't do it too much and then
very importantly with your body language
use your facial expressions to draw
people in the same goes for your tone of
voice as well I mean I think I'll boring
it will be if I have no facial
expressions and if I just talk the same
way with no different tones in my voice
the whole time yeah you see what I mean
facial expressions kind of help people
to just feel your words and not just
hear it just like your tone of voice and
the space between your words for example
I can say one sentence very very
differently so can you for example I
love my wife I love my wife I love my
wife I love my wife I love my wife I
love my wife you see what I'm saying
[Music]
video editing this can either make or
break your videos because look you're
gonna make a lot of mistakes when you
film yourself this is gonna happen I
still make a lot of mistakes and this is
the part where you cut out all them
unnecessary mistakes and the parts that
are not so important all that all the
fat now if you have just a little bit
experience in editing videos then it
will help you to film your videos as
well why because while you're filming
you're already thinking a little bit
about the editing part you know what
part you can fix and what part you can't
fix and you have to phone all over again
you should never think that when you're
gonna film a video that everything will
go perfectly
it won't remember there's a lot of other
things that's also gonna bother you
noises what and the airplane this time
is a bike birds big truck
neighbors so believe me it's not always
easy to film a video there's a lot of
noises and things that just go wrong so
sometimes you'll have to say the same
thing over and over and over again until
you're a happy with it and then you cut
all those pieces you bring it together
and then you have your video you can
then add music to create the right
feeling and then you can add some b-roll
you can change up the color and then
even add some transitions and graphics
to it so it looks more professional and
hey you can learn all of this on YouTube
[Music]
speak clearly and slowly not a mean slow
motion but your tempo should just be at
a tempo that people can follow what
you're saying now I used to speak too
fast in the beginning very very very
fast and people could not follow what I
was saying
especially if English is not their first
language people need to understand what
you're saying and also keep up with what
you're saying
remember when you explain something when
you talk about something you already
know it they don't know it yet when they
hear it for the first time they need to
hear they need to process it and then
they need to take it in to understand it
that takes some time and if you speak
clearly and slow or not slow but at the
right pace then you will also come
across as being more confident because
you'll be more in control of your speech
now remember your first videos will be
your worst every new thing in life that
you start for the first time is usually
heart it's unknown you don't know how to
do it until you get the experience and
master it now I'm gonna show you just a
few bloopers just to show you that I
still struggle with filming as well
enjoy look like a robot and slowly I
don't connect with people and it's a
very better habit very very very very
very very too much varies
okay see that
[Music]
okay last one last one
good good good I'm some coffee but I
call that pretty cheap
turn the page let it flow naturally